[Musique]
bienvenue à la une de paris saclay tv la
ligne 18 du métro grand paris express
avec une étape importante le baptême du
premier tunnelier le chantier vous le
voyez il est juste ici à palaiseau et on
vous y emmène dans quelques instants
nous allons aller dans les tréfonds de
palaiseau c'est une étape importante une
étape importante pour ce projet
pharaonique avec le confinement et la
crise sanitaire nous avons dû apprendre
à travailler autrement le pea paris
saclay mise sur le coworking avec une
semaine dédiée objectif faire découvrir
au plus grand nombre cinq lieux de
partage cinq lieux hybride pour
travailler autrement nous irons aussi à
la découverte de l'architecturé
contemporaine de votre territoire des
balades urbaines vous ont permis de
découvrir des bâtiments signés par des
grands noms allez je vous en cite
quelques uns renzo piano home à grafton
architectes faisons pas sonner votre
territoire visites guidées à l'occasion
des journées nationales de
l'architecturé et puis nous nous
retournerons à palaiseau pour visiter
une place une toute nouvelle place
baptisée par great pleurer à cause de la
crise sanitaire le chantier avait pris
du retard aujourd'hui c'est fait elle
est inaugurée et le maire de la ville le
maire de palaiseau s'en félicite vous
entendrez grégoire de lasteyrie et enfin
notre agenda ce sera à la fin de cette
émission
la ligne 18 du métro grand paris express
elle sera mise en service en 2026 et je
vous le disais une étape importante
vient d'être franchie le baptême du
premier tunnelier celui de la partie est
à palaiseau je me trouve actuellement au
delà du symbole c'est le coup d'envoi
d'une grande aventure une aventure qui
va transformer votre territoire retour
sur cette cérémonie qui a réuni les
principaux acteurs de ce chantier
impressionnant
aujourd'hui nous sommes sur le site des
ouvrages camille claudel à palaiseau qui
est le site sur lequel le premier
tunnelier de la partie s de l'année 18
va démarrer donc dans deux mois
maintenant et l'objectif de cette
journée c'était de le présenter
aux partenaires locaux et de faire ce
qu'on appelle le baptême donc avec la
bouteille de champagne rituel pour
marquer le coup de ce démarrage du
creusement du tunnel sur la ville de
palayson n'est pas une science exacte le
creusement des tunnels la vitesse
moyenne sur laquelle on compte c'est de
12 à 15 mètres
par jour c'est vraiment des vitesses
moyennes il ya des jours le tunisie va
beaucoup plus vite et puis il ya des
moments où
ça se passe moins bien dans ce cas là il
va très lentement notamment quand il
rencontre un sol difficile il ya aussi
des périodes de maintenance programmés
puisque évidemment c'est de la mécanique
de précision de temps en temps comme
pour votre voiture il faut l'arrêter
pour faire la révision est donc ça on le
fait de manière programmée pour éviter
les zones géotechnique difficile donc
pour être sûr que le tunnel devrait
s'arrêter en sécurité pouvoir redémarrer
dans de bonnes conditions
pour l'instant le calendrier est tenu le
programme de travail et même un petit
peu en avance puisque on va démarrer le
creusement avec ce tunnelier de novembre
de sept années 2000 vingt-et-une le
deuxième tunnelier lui qui serait
baptisé dans un mois démarre en
descendre donc on est tout à fait en
phase pour les mises en service de 2026
et 2027 qui sont le calendrier qui est
actuellement prévu sur la partie est de
la ligne pour la partie ouest de la
ligne dans les yvelines donc le
calendrier prévoit toujours une mise en
service en 2030 et pour l'instant on est
aussi en phase sur nos préparatifs la
même si les travaux n'ont pas commencé
les études se poursuivent en vue de
tenir ce calendrier
le baptême du tunnelier ça va au delà de
l'événement symbolique c'est un moment
très très fort je les rappeler tout à
l'heure à la tribune d'abord pour les
équipes qui travaillent sur ce chantier
d'arrache-pied je dois dire avec un
engagement sans faille extrêmement
important l'aspect de la tradition du
baptême du tunnelier et est important
pour ces types de professions et je veux
vraiment saluer mois lançant des
personnes qui se sont mobilisées pour
arriver à ce moment-là moment qui n'est
qu'un début on commence à creuser et on
est parti pour la grande aventure
concrète de la ligne 18 ans au sein du
grand paris express
avec la crise sanitaire notre vie a été
bouleversée par exemple nous avons
appris à travailler à la maison
aujourd'hui faut donc repenser nos
façons de travailler voilà pourquoi le
pea paris saclay vous propose le
coworking une semaine pour découvrir
cinq lieux de partage saint cloud
hybride entre télétravail et entreprises
il y à une troisième voie que nous
présente frédéric devrait ve il est chef
de projet innovation et développement
économique de le paix à paris saclay
c'est la première semaine du coworking à
paris saclay donc c'est une initiative
qui est née d'un groupe de travail cinq
lieux d'innovation de paris saclay cinq
structures se sont réunis dans le cade
en fait d'une communauté public plus
large qui est là comité des lieux
d'innovation que le pea paris saclay à
nîmes avec le concours des trois
communes et d'agglomérations et des deux
pôles académique donc de de ce cluster
de paris saclay et l'idée justement
c'était de mettre en avant ces lieux de
les ouvrir au public et à différents
types de publics de population que ce
soit le grand public des entrepreneurs
des indépendants des salariés puisque
aujourd'hui on voit les modes de travail
qui sont en train d'évoluer et on a de
plus en plus besoin de ce type de lieux
qui sont hybrides entre le travail chez
soi et le travail au bureau ou en
entreprise et ça permet donc de créer
vraiment d ambiance assez sympathique et
plus créative pour l'ensemble de ces
populations
les cinq lieux qui ont composé le
jugement ce groupe de travail des lieux
de coworking de paris saclay sont le 21
c'est un tout nouveau pour le coup
espace de coworking à orsay sur le
plateau de saclay la terrasse discovery
donc à saint-aubin qui est opéré par la
banque populaire val de france le l'oma
qui est un espace plutôt dédié à tous
qui environnement audiovisuel quitte à
massy la chambre de commerce de
versailles et enfin sur lui en cours
generis accueillera la dernière étape de
cette semaine du coworking et c'est un
lieu plutôt orienté prototypage
sur tout ce qui est électronique
mécanique
aujourd'hui nous sommes à la terrasse
discovery la deuxième étape de cette
semaine du coworking donc évidemment il
propose différents types d' espaces
c'est aussi un espace qui va accueillir
des formations puisqu'on ya un nombre de
salles de réunion assez importante et on
a également des grands espaces
événementiels pour accueillir voilà des
séminaires ou des réunions beaucoup plus
conséquente et devrait aussi prise prise
de conscience est de mise en action des
régions pour créer ce type de tir lieu
qui va permettre un petit peu de
réconcilier le travail foule bureau et
de travail complètement à la maison et
qui sont donc des lieux intermédiaires
mais également donc de partage on va
pouvoir retrouver un petit peu une
hybridation de ce qu'on retrouve au
bureau et dans ceux qu'on peut retrouver
à la maison en termes de profondeur de
travail
[Musique]
partons à présent à la découverte de
l'architecturé contemporaine de votre
territoire les journées nationales de
l'architecturé vous ont permis de
découvrir d'admirer des bâtiments créé
par de grands noms je cite quelques
exemples
le ms l'école normale supérieure paris
saclay certaines zones piano télécom
paris c'est grafton architectes où on a
encore brûlures et beau qu'une ce qui
crée une résidence étudiante quand vous
avez raté ces journées nationales de
l'architecturé bien petite session de
rattrapage avec dominique rérat
architectes de l'atelier piano
[Musique]
dans le cadre des journées de
l'architecturé
le p a fait visiter ses cibles de
projets
en particulier sur le sud du plateau de
saclay donc les quartiers de boulons et
l'école polytechnique
et cette année nous avons ajouté à ces
visites une visite un peu particulière
qui est celle du site qui se trouve
derrière moi on est sur l'usiné thomson
pour laquelle j'ai participé au sein de
l' agence renzo piano en
un bâtiment de 30 mille mètres carrés
situé à saint quentin en yvelines sur
l'ancien aérodrome de guyancourt un
terrain gigantesque de 22 hectares et
qui maintenant est complètement démolie
à 90% pour laisser la place à une zac la
zac des savoirs
et ça c'est absolument extraordinaire de
voir trente ans plus tard que ce projet
va avoir une deuxième vie finalement et
ça c'est très impressionnant pour un
architecte de voir que son bâtiment va
être réutilisées
ce site va constituer l'entrée du
quartier des savoirs qui lui sera un des
nouveaux quartiers de guyancourt autour
du métro et qui va accueillir environ
1800 logements et tous les équipements
et commerces qui accompagne ce type de
nouveaux quartiers
il ya beaucoup de choses à refaire donc
ça ça va être la première étape pendant
ce temps là le chantier va se faire il
va y avoir une une interaction entre les
deux et puis peut-être qu'un jour on va
faire la réhabilitation définitive de la
halle qui est une phase ultérieure
on va remettre en eau normes ce bâtiment
mais en lui gardant son caractère son
caractère toujours un peu industriels
il est important pour nous de faire
découvrir nos sites de projets parce
qu'en général ce sont des sites fermés
un petit peu méconnu du public qui sont
cachés derrière une clôture et donc des
journées comme celle-ci sont l'occasion
de les faire découvrir un petit peu
avant l'heure avant qu'ils deviennent de
vrais lieux de destination pour les
habitants du territoire
le chantier avait pris du retard
qu'ovide oblige la place marguerite
pleurer du nom de cette brillante
chimiste française est bel et bien
terminée voilà qui méritait une
inauguration en grande pompe et en
musique avec la fanfare de l'école
polytechnique de nombreux élus étaient
présents à commencer par le maire de
palaiseau grégoire de lasteyrie
[Musique]
où
oh
nous venons d'inaugurer la place
marguerite père est au coeur du plateau
de saclay sur la commune de palaiseau
cet après midi et j'ai été extrêmement
fiers de pouvoir à la dénommée
marguerite perret en l'honneur de cette
grande scientifique cette chimiste
suisse nucléaire qui au début du 20e
siècle a eu de nombreux travaux avec
marie curie avec irène joliot curie et a
été notamment en 1962 la première femme
à entrer à l'académie des sciences
c'était important que sur ce quartier
qui est au coeur de l'innovation
française au coeur de la recherche
française nous mettions à l'honneur des
scientifiques et en particulier des
femmes scientifiques il y a trop peu
dans notre pays deux noms de rues de
noms de places qui sont dénommées après
des femmes est ici à palaiseau et en
particules sur le plateau de saclay
c'était pour nous quelque chose
d'extrêmement important notamment par
rapport aux faits scientifiques qui est
majeure
cette place est un lieu de vie pour le
quartier il y aura évidemment de
nombreux commerces vous voyez derrière
moi une boulangerie un supermarché un
restaurant qui est déjà présent ça sera
aussi la place qui sera en face de la
future gare du métro de la ligne 18
quand il sera là en 2026 mais
régulièrement il y aura beaucoup
d'événementiel qui pourront avoir lieu
ici ça sera vraiment le coeur battant du
quartier
[Musique]
place à notre agenda avec des rendez
vous culturels et ludiques comme le
domino day hashtag 4 c'est à palaiseau
est donc le grand retour de cette
épreuve c'est du 25 au 29 octobre
l'objectif ou battre un nouveau record
alors venez aider à la mise en place des
dominos puis rendez vous le vendredi 29
octobre pour la chute finale c'est à 20
heures précises la prochaine réunion des
associations c'est le 23 novembre alors
c'est ouvert uniquement aux associations
et au collectif citoyen inscription sur
contact at on tiré paris saclay point fr
deux rendez vous culturels à ne surtout
pas rater avec déjà la nuit du cirque
c'est le samedi 13 novembre à 20h30 à la
ferme de bel ébat 7 à guyancourt
quatre spectacles de cirque pour une
soirée qui s'annonce inoubliable
vous voulez découvrir l'opéra autrement
eh bien ne ratez pas le dit opéra locaux
c'est le 20 novembre à 20h45 palaiseau
théâtre de la passerelle alors avec cinq
chanteurs d'opéra qui se réunissent pour
interpréter les airs les plus connus
le tout pimenté de pop vous allez passer
là aussi une soirée qui s'annonce
vraiment vraiment vraiment intéressante
et c'est déjà la fin de cette émission
alors non je ne chanterai pas mais je
vous dis à très bientôt pour un nouveau
numéro de paris saclay de tv et d'ici là
restez informé sur notre site le pap est
ce point fr a très vite
[Musique]